start of it was to make sure that people
saw you know our passion for the film in
this project that just you know passion
for filmmaking and acting and you know
in general so I'm glad we did that you
know I'm really proud of what we've done
so far and you know I'm definitely am
confident that our amber is going to
resonate the same way and it's a really
good screenplay not just saying that
because I robe it d is really good
ladies picky picky hey I don't ya again
it's one of the good things where you go
back to uh how do you know what makes a
good friendship or collaboration and
stuff like that is because he would not
spare me an inch if I wrote something
the hill re what he will know anything
and I trust in that you know that means
so that that's definitely one cuz you
know there's tons hate that scene I
thought it should have ended a little
different and he'll tell me his
interpretation of the inner you know I
think as a writer you have to be able to
take criticism you can't be like oh you
don't like it I'm not listening to you
it's like you could stumble into
something great but who are you writing
it for you or for everyone you're trying
to present the project to so the other
people's ideas and you know comments on
it you know should you know kind of
going to your writing at least be taken
into consideration so it's good that he
wouldn't spare me and that's what makes
our friendship better awesome because a
lot of people who have a lot of friends
but so-called friends if they have a
they have a scraper to have a movie the
ball that's awesome that's good but
behind it back it was off but they won't
tell your friend yeah yeah I will tell
him yeah i was telling if he's horrible
was telling if it's good same thing with
him he will tell me what I'm doing
something wrong and you know that's how
you keep a close friendship yeah and it
me is you know as especially as a writer
you know the you want to hear it's great
but you don't get any you can't take
much from that it's great yeah but if
it's like oh I like it but this part
here it kind of left me feeling this and
this and you know what I mean in it and
and it kind of confused me for a minute
and things like that and it's just like
I want to hear is great but I really
to hear the parts that kind of left the
person in the wind a little bit because
there's a screenwriter I'll go back and
tighten those things and you know I take
into account when I you know you need to
have your core people then you can take
a project to and that you're going to
get really good feedback and honest you
know feedback from and guidance on it
and you know with that you take that
going back and you're going to Connor
revisit the project with those
criticisms in mind and and rewrite it
and structure it and also that it
appeals to everyone as well as yourself
so you know being able to take criticism
is very important what about giving
criticism what's your advice on that
giving criticism I always try to give
criticism you know if you know with a
solution in mind you know at the same
time so I'll say oh I I don't like that
maybe you should be like this let's try
it like this and like let's try it like
this it's like but to just say I don't
like that guy you know kind of just
leaving in with what don't you like well
you know what is it this is it this all
you know I try to be really concise and
if I'm giving criticism to give a
straightforward criticism this is what I
like this is what I didn't like this is
why it made me feel like this and this
and to me that's the information that a
writer could take anybody could take
back and at least you know revisit it
you might think my words are like I
won't listen nobody you know saying
because every criticism is it's
different you know and you have to take
some with a grain of salt some work for
your project and what you're doing and
others don't but at least it's clear
it's concise and you know how I feel
about a topic or something you know what
with me i'm more more rough on people so
people tend not to come to me for
basically let's say I have a friend have
a friend in New York is a single who's
also a rapper become you enjoy what you
think about this I don't like I'm gonna
let you know and i'ma tell you is
horrible I don't like it any wise like
if that's my mother I just really just
doesn't matter just don't like it but
after after telling how I feel they
won't talk to me for a month but they
want to keep hearing a big after those
other people in the car in the corner
tell hotel me all is good is all
you're great you don't know what you're
talking about haha but behind it back to
come to meet your ancient man you write
me nuts music is horrible but I'm more
ruffling people because again the world
is not the word it's not basically I
will be living right now it's not easy
and I me it's very hard i have people
gonna be tortured so you were rather you
rather hear your friend or your family
may tell you the truth in a complete
stranger and it's not telling you what
stuff do you want to hear you know so I
more roughing people i tell them
actually telling the truth so they won't
have nobody or some other stuff Cedeno
saying so I just telling how it is
that's me yeah and you you're okay what
people doing the same yeah yeah that's
that's not that's all there yeah work
yeah so work well when I go when I'm in
a jam they've got all yo your great
fight oh gee oh I know that love you
copy your left when you throw the right
you left your slip yeah yeah tell me yo
exactly i know that but can you see my
flaws no no no not me but he sees it you
know I me but they won't tell me the
truth I want somebody be honest and
targeted term the truth about what I'm
doing so that's how I'm gonna keep on
blunt and then I just keep it real with
him that's how he is for me and that's
what we work together yeah I uh when I
tell himself he is feeling won't get
hurt when he told me something my
feelings won't get hurt the thing about
a lot of writers they get the right did
they write this script and they get so
connected with it they fall in love with
it and then um they already have an idea
how this script is supposed to be and
they don't want to hate nobody tell him
nothing and that's the key thing to
remember earlier I said I don't wear my
heart on the sleeve when I'm writing it
only wear my heart on my sleeve when I'm
making it actually shooting it and
that's the reason why so I don't get so
connected to the project that I can't
take the criticism to validly look at
the project and see what it is and take
that person's criticism and apply it to
the script you know so it is like that's
the main reason why I'm very analytical
I'm very it's a it's a it's a product to
me until I create something viable that
I know is strong and I'm ready to move
forward it now could put my heart on my
sleeve and let everybody see how much I
really care about this and I can inject
but I can't do it early because then you
get to connected to it it too emotional
too attached to it and then it's hard to
cut pages you know and at times as a
writer you didn't no matter how many
matter how hard it was for you to come
up with that scene sometimes you got to
look at it and put it next to it all and
say I'm not going to use it and get rid
of it and if you can't do that as a
writer you can't get better because
you'll hit a ceiling and you won't be
willing to change and adapt in order to
break through that ceiling and get
better so that you stop at that point
when you're not willing to you know
really criticize yourself whoa
you